acting is kind of scary and your you
have to operate whilst your head is
attacking you if you're me anyway
I never watch anything I mean if I can
possibly help it because I find it takes
too long to recover and I have to go to
work I don't mind watching if I do
cartoons for instance I was I was once
required to be a squid man in a movie I
was an octopus guy and it was all
digitally achieved so uh and I was
perfectly happy watching that because
what are you going to say mice you don't
like my squid well then you know live
with it because it's your problem and
also I had a very successful my squid
was world class my squid was an
award-winning square because the hundred
men and women who created my squid that
the first thing the director said to
them when they presented the squid was
get your acceptance speech ready and
they won an Oscar so I was in very good
company with the squid I had I was put
into a pair of very sad computer pajamas
which had white bubbles velcroed all
over them and I was then given a skull
cap with a white bubble on the top and I
was given 250 I think it was white dots
all over my face and then introduced to
Johnny Depp and if you ask me are there
any great challenges in my professional
career one of my greatest challenges was
wondering about a very big American film
set dressed in pajamas with white dots
all over your face with crew members
being kind enough but actually averting
their eyes because they couldn't bring
themselves to look at you because it was
so sad you know and then you are shown a
picture of the scariest thing on the
ocean waves which is the squid and then
they say action
that's you know not going to the airport
and just saying please let me go home is
one of my proudest achievements and I'm
not even kidding when I was younger and
in you know you'd be in digs up and down
the country and hanging out in bars with
actors and it would get to that part of
the conversation where actors discussed
their process I would go to the men's
room or put the cattle up or just go
quiet because my my dreadful secret was
that I didn't have a process and I still
don't have a process and I and I just
never got around to having a process the
standing questions are how much research
did you do for this part and I am old
enough now and it's refreshing when
you're younger you have to lie but when
you're my age are allowed to say if you
ask me the question how much research
did I do for this part the answer is
absolutely none whatsoever because I
work at a level of writing where
anything I need to know any of the
information usually is in the script at
there's something specific you go ask
but it's very rare and also they say how
did you get into character well I'm also
old enough to say that I've never
knowingly been in character in my life
I've heard great things about it but
it's just outside of my experience I
don't actually know what they're talking
about
I was approached in the street recently
by a young woman who said that she'd
seen me in a play and she very much
enjoyed very much enjoyed it and I said
well thank you and she said I'm trying
to be an actor and I said how's that
going she said well I'm having a little
trouble with my drama teacher I said
what kind of trouble you're having with
a drama teacher she said well I'm having
difficulty with the feelings I said
feelings she said like I would you know
she said you know the feelings like I
would know I said you saw me in a play
she said yeah and you and you you
thought it was good she said I was
absolutely well I said well I can
absolutely guarantee you that I'm not
feeling anything I'm at work generally
I'm a bit busy I'm a bit pushed I have
to do I have to achieve about 1,500
things over a period
two and a half hours or whatever the
play length might be I have to make love
to a woman smoke cigarettes reach the
door handle hit the door handle when
that verbal cue comes because otherwise
the lights will go funny I have to you
know get semi naked and eat chili con
carne
you know I'm occupied I can't be feeling
stuff you know that I do in my own time
and you can't phone up on a wet
Wednesday and say you know what I'm not
feeling it so I don't think I'll come in
today people who teach acting they have
to talk for a very long time sometimes
two years of talk or sometimes three and
there isn't that much to say and they
start making it up sometimes
or they'll concentrate on things that
are undeniable that you can't say I am
feeling it now you know now I can't you
know you're not fit I can't I'm sorry I
just you're not feeling you go you've
got a few yeah I am I think I'm cleaning
you know it's all it's completely
unnecessary the audience have no
interest in what you might be feeling
you're supposed to give the appearance
of feeling something like you did when
you were a kid it is an extension of
what you did in the backyard when you
played the bank robber and the other guy
played the policeman there are many
myths and and there are there are also
PR myths and everybody's supposed to toe
the line and and I'd like with
everything else the truth always works
better and I'm not saying that other
people are lying I'm saying that you
know people you know it's just it's just
my view but I do think that sometimes
younger actors are manipulated in a
certain way it's it's it's a matter of
control and they are made to feel that
there is something that's out of their
range or out of their reach there's
nothing that's out of
Ranger out of your reach don't assume
that you have to take off your clothes
it's [ __ ] there is no plot to which
it's essential it's usually broadly
speaking by extension it's a budgetary
concern from the producers like it it's
got very little to do with ARC it's got
nothing to do with art and it has
nothing to do with truth I don't know if
there is a secret to collaboration with
other actors I've never been asked this
question before it's a good question
usually it's if I think what is exciting
is when you realize that your fellow
actor is entirely prepared and that
whatever preparation has been required
has taken place elsewhere and then if
everybody is prepared then you can start
to rock there isn't that another myth
and it's almost become a kind of way in
which people demonstrate their status
which is not to know your lines
the myth is propped up with a particular
piece of Tosh and the Tosh is if you
learn your lines before going into a
rehearsal situation for instance you
will become imprisoned by inter nations
and therefore that is a discuss
discourtesy to your fellow professionals
that's a complete and utter myth made up
by people who didn't want to do their
homework that's it it's entered the
language and it's become refined over
the years and it's now you know it's as
if it's uncreated to know your lines or
uncreated to have studied them in any
great depth that we are supposed to wait
for lightning or the muse or something
well I operate without abuse and without
lightning because I've got one and I am
got any backing is pretty
straightforward and it's not you know
it's and it's actions and you need to be
sort of directed and told I like I do
like being told what to do when I work
first with Steven Polyakov
my first job for him as it were that the
first thing I was required to do was to
tell George v played by Tom Hollander
that the whole of the Russian side of
his family had been slaughtered in a
basement the previous day that was my
first day's work with Stephen polygon
and I did it and he came over and he
said that was very very good don't
wiggle your eyes about so much and I
rejoiced because I know how to do that
he didn't come over and say I think you
should employ more secondary energy
rather than primary energy because you
know Ben went and he didn't he didn't go
into psych psychiatric terminology which
because then I'm lost the early days of
walking on sets when no one knows who
you are
you have no credits to kind of proceed
you you you feel intimidated and you are
inexperienced which is fine you know
you're supposed to be obviously those
were the most challenging times a young
actor phoned me from his trailer and he
was about to start a job a film job it
was a big job and he'd never really done
a lot before and and he they told him
that he had 20 minutes before he was
going onto the set for the first time
the first day of the job and between us
we decided that that's what you get paid
for you get paid for the 20 minutes in
the trailer before you walk on the set
lots of people think I could probably be
an actor but they don't know about the
20 minutes in the trailer before you
walk on and that's the tough debt
remember that no one knows what's going
on in your head and they never will and
I know that sounds stupid but it's it's
a good thing to remember and remember
that you're supposed to be scared that's
the normal healthy natural reaction to
the job that you're about
you know to walk on to a into a
professional situation where there are
lots and lots of people all under
pressure would usually not enough money
everyone's exhausted and to be at some
point know that someone's going to say
action and everyone's going to
scrutinize you for a while or at least
you're and you would imagine that they
are they don't know what's going on in
your head and if you're prepared then
you're in the kind of shape you don't
believe any reputations the matter how
many awards or public distinctions
they've been given let them prove it to
you we're in treatment with courtesy
obviously treat everybody with courtesy
that's that's a sign of great
professionalism and it's you know that's
anything other than that is
unprofessional Christopher Walken is
someone who I you know I passionately
admire everything he every move he makes
his poetic and Michael Gambon is is my
role model thank you Michael and Gene
Hackman might be somebody I admire
tremendously and isabellew pair and a
great French actress is someone who if
you're ever in doubt about you know that
there's dignity in what you do and that
there's some future in art check out
anything that is a better parent
that will refresh you'll you'll
enthusiasm